[Music]
so uh i'm the voice of the e-trade baby
i don't know if anybody knew that i'm
the yeah i'm the baby i'm that baby and
my parents who are obviously here
tonight are very big fans of that um i
think that's because that's the only
thing i've done in my career that airs
during jeopardy
and uh my father this is true from time
to time will call me and leave me
voicemails where he gives me fun
suggestions for ideas like different
scenarios the e-trade baby could be in
in a future commercial uh
just to introduce you to jay holmes he's
the owner of an oil tank removal service
outside of boston called tanks a lot
that's real
tanks
thanks a lot
uh
so pop it's an honor to have you here
for today's installment of a bit we've
been doing on the show called voicemails
from my dad
[Applause]
casting gas
i think
that
somehow or another you should get them
to stay at the very end of this
commercial log on
you know i can see it now that little
boy pete i believe is his name
with that little
surprise look at his face saying log on
anyway
call your mother
[Applause]
yeah that's my dad everybody
[Music]
you